Current left-wing Sarah Wagenknecht wants to
start her own party with a small team of Allies 2,024.
The traffic light government is haphazard despite numerous
crises in the world and Germany has an absurdly poor infrastructure,
Wagenknecht said in Berlin on Monday.
And, of course,
this unsettles many people.
Many no longer know what to choose or choose Out of Anger and Despair.
Right,
we decided to create a new party because we are convinced.
The way things are going at present,
we must not go on,
because otherwise we will probably not recognize our country in 10 years.
Wagenknecht demanded that the country move away from a black eco-course.
In addition,
she said the opinion corridor in Germany must be broadened again.
Anyone who deviates from a quote dominant
opinion bubble is quickly defamed and stigmatizes me,
he said.
I have experienced this myself because,
like many countries in the South or,
for example,
U.S. border cooperation,
I am promoting a negotiated solution in Ukraine.
I have also been described again and again as putina or
pro-Russian by many colleagues who are present here today,
and I would really like to make an appeal to them in this context.
It is your legitimate right not to like us and to
prefer other parties or not to share our positions,
but please deal factually with what we stand for and don't go the cheap
way of insinuating things that we don't represent at all to us or to put
or bring ourselves close to dubious people with whom we have nothing to do.
To prepare for the formation of the party,
Wagenknecht and her team have created an association,
chaired by the previous CO. faction leader of the left,
Amira Mohammed Ali.
This morning Sarah wanknecht,
Christian Leie,
Lukas schön and I left the left together with 7
other members of the left-wing parliamentary group.
This decision was not easy for us.
After all,
the left was the political home for us for many years,
even decades.
Immediately we are convinced that the 1.
Necessary and right step was.
The left has not corrected its course despite repeated
re-election defeats and is on its way to insignificance,
Mohammed Ali said.
Experts do not trust the new party to 1 greater part,
and protest voters to unite.
For the left,
this could be the death blow.